Es spricht einiges dafür in deutschland genauer an der grenze zu tschechien steht ein landstrich wohl kurz vor einem vulkanausbruch
so geologen jedenfalls sprechen die schwarmbeben dort dafür dass ich etwas unter der erde tut
und es gibt noch einige indizien jetzt in kriegs und science fiction bei uns gibt's täglich solche spannenden themen abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
Ein vulkan in deutschland ja und das ist gar nicht mal so abwegig die eifel ist zum beispiel ein
aktives vulkangebiet jedenfalls für geologen auch hier
steigen zurzeit die aktivitäten unter dem mittelgebirge der lara sie ist ein vulkan der
erst vor 11.000 jahren ausgebrochen ist für geologen
quasi erst vor kurzem zitat wir haben im untergrund eine veränderung die aus dem mantel kommt und die zu einer magma bildung führen kann
es sei eine frage der zeit waren hier genug magma angereichert ist das dann den vulkan speist und einen neuen ausbruch
auslöst so der essener geologie professor ulrich schreiber unter dem vulkankrater liegt eine magmakammer
und das kann noch hunderte von jahren dauern oder auch
unvorhersehbar stellt wir sollten gewappnet sein schätz geologe schreiber ob sie und das ganze ist auch messbar
forschungsteams beobachten
seismische ereignisse
gasaktivitäten
oder
bodenbewegungen zum beispiel co2 austritt im lara see also gasbläschen im wasser es gebe hohe
ausgaben und rohrrahmen werte dort sagt schreiber in bad ems komme co2 aus der tiefe und durch das wasser der lahn
sieht man das aufsteigen und es gibt sogar leichte erdbeben die darauf hindeuten dass sich die magma kammer unter dem see füllt im jahr
2016 wurden im bereich der osteifel
42 natürlich erdbeben gemessen wow was aber gar nichts gegen das vogtland ist hier im dreiländereck von bayern sachsen und tschechien
gab es im früher 1000 beben sogenannten schwarmbeben jedes zehnte davon
konnten auch die bewohner dort spüren
100 also wow und es ist tatsächlich so dort wird eine zunehmende aktivität
beobachtet zitat
wir glauben dass wir einen erwachenden vulkan beobachten so der sektionsleiter der erdbeben-und vulkan physik vom
zentrum in potsdam potsdam
zuvor musste im ego becken dort fühlt sich wohl ein
maresa war und noch etwas kommt dazu wie in der eifel globale co2 auf dem boden in rund 50 kilometern tiefe
setzt heißes magma dieses gas frei das ist schon mal klar noch heißt das gar nichts und trotzdem wollen die forscher und forscherinnen
der region näher untersuchen denn nach geologischer zeitrechnung erst vor
300.000 jahren sind dort zwei vulkane aktiv gewesen kabul und eisen bilden jetzt will ein
internationales forschungsteam der gefahr auf den grund gehen im wahrsten sinne des wortes ganz tief bohren und die frage klären ist dort eine mark mark
kamera die zu einem vulkanausbruch
führt oder nicht bis in 4000 meter tiefe will das team bohren damit soll geklärt werden ob und wann dort ein vulkan ausbrechen könnte in
30 jahren
könnte es schon so weit sein dorf sagt im fokus man sollte unbedingt die chancen für eine region sehen ob sie
vulkan tourismus als chance das würde auf jeden fall mitteleuropa ziemlich verändern wenn hier vor unserer nase
vulkane ausbrechen würden ja aber wenn man sich die eifel anschaut ist das gar nicht so absurd immerhin wurde er wegen der erdbebengefahr
ausgelöst durch den vulkanismus das kernkraftwerk mülheim kärlich wieder stillgelegt ein vulkan in deutschland unwahrscheinlich
wohl nicht wir halten euch hier auf dem laufenden
klicks und gibt es jetzt übrigens auch auf englisch wenn ihr freuen darf die englisch sprechen oder mit mir
besser englisch sprechen lernen wollt dann abonniert den kanal das geht hier am besten einfach draufklicken
jede woche drei videos und darunter geht es weiter mit ice age im
euroville begann stream come to install bis dann
bleib dran